audience questions this week first one
is a good one I've actually told a lot
of friends these stories and I don't
think I've told them on the show the
question is have you ever overheard
people talking about you in Spanish
thinking you couldn't understand how did
you react there's actually a lot of
these stories and for people who don't
know English is my second language
Spanish my first language I was born in
Argentina my family's from Argentina
immigrated to the United States when I
was five years old so many many times I
have overheard people speaking about me
in Spanish there was one time I think
the first time it really happened
notably was when I worked at a laser tag
place when I was in high school and
people would come in I would tell them
how much it cost they would pay I give
them their change I give them their
equipment bla ba ba ba ba and there was
a family that came in the family they it
was a Hispanic family they spoke to each
other in Spanish and there was something
I must have done that they really didn't
like so as I was walking away they
hurled some kind of insult at me to each
other they said this is whatever I don't
remember what the term was but it was
all in Spanish and I grabbed their
change and I went back and in Spanish I
said something like a lot of people
speak Spanish and you got to be really
careful about who can understand you and
they looked very shocked and very very
embarrassed and did not say another word
to me the entire time and it was the
parents and only the kids were playing
the laser tag stuff so they kind of had
to like sit out there in pretty close
proximity to me for the entire time Wow
no apologies or anything no apologies
however just lovely silence and they
were very very surprised about that
there's been a lot of similar incidents
to that they're not always negative like
sometimes there will be a discussion
like you know in New York City I would
go to a restaurant and I would just say
you know table for four or whatever and
then there would be a discussion amongst
the hostess and maybe a waiter or
something like that about where it is
that they want to see us and there will
be some question as to whether we would
or wouldn't be ok in a certain spot like
do they want to sit outside or not and
then I'll just respond in Spanish and
say we actually would love to sit
outside and usually there's no
conversation in New York it's it's not
actually surprising to anybody so then
it's just kind of like oh ok yeah let's
just go outside and then only later
we'll do something
say oh you're speaking Spanish to us
yeah or something like that but the most
glaring one is that time at the laser
tag thing where the people were actually
calling me you know a prick or whatever
and I said a lot a lot of people speak
Spanish you got to be careful you ever
go to like a Mexican restaurant or a
Spanish restaurant and insist on
speaking Spanish and they think that
you're just some gringo trying to speak
it as a Second Language
no and they'll just revert right back to
English how does that work only time
that that has happened
so most native Spanish speakers would
identify that I speak Spanish and the
only time that it was different was I
think I've told the story before I once
went on vacation to one of the Balearic
Balearic I think is how you pronounce it
islands off the coast of Spain they're
Spanish islands and these islands are
very very heavily trafficked by both
British and German tourists and there
was a restaurant that I actually went to
that was a quote Spanish restaurant but
it was owned by a German woman and she
was she spoke Spanish as a second
language in other words she's German
she moved to Spain learn Spanish and
runs the Spanish restaurant I didn't
know that she was German because I'm in
Spain so I assumed when someone comes up
we're gonna be speaking in Spanish and
she assumed that I didn't speak Spanish
and because of my Argentinian accent
because she was a Spanish as a second
language speaker to her it just sounded
weird rather than recognizing that it's
Argentinian Spanish so she actually not
only did she insist on speaking English
she corrected my Spanish multiple times
on a way that was very very
condescending as if because they weren't
mistakes they were just Argentinian
Spanish she's an outrage and she didn't
even her Spanish was was so poor that
she didn't even recognize what was going
on like we got to the end of the meal
and she believed that I was just you
know an American who didn't speak
Spanish and that because her she spoke
English and I couldn't speak Spanish we
were better off communicating in English
so it was a little bit surreal I went to
Spain and communicated with a German
restaurant owner in English like what do
you even do in that scenario you don't
want to give your whole life story right
I want to get on with your day so I just
spoke English with her you know what was
the point of going any further than that
so yep needless to say it's happened
times and in some cases it's been pretty
embarrassing for the other person